with only ten days left to go the
drumbeat of discontent inside the
administration is growing louder Iran
you know has not shown good faith it
cannot be trusted
but will the Iran nuclear deal survive
without the US according to senior
British government officials it can they
tell Fox News the deal will live without
u.s. participation but the deal is based
on a quid pro quo system of sanctions if
President Trump pulls out the u.s. could
be forced to punish other countries that
continue trading with Iran that's why
national security experts are advocating
for what they describe as a soft exit to
avoid a major breakdown in trade
relations with Europe the president will
give a grace period of perhaps six
months to allow the Europeans to
continue negotiating with Iran but at
that six-month point in time the
president is going to have to start
lowering the boom on European companies
but trade is a double-edged sword for
Europeans Iranian exports to the EU
increased by three hundred and seventy
five percent after the deal was inked
all the other countries that signed on
to the 2015 framework agreement remain
committed to it and behind the scenes
they've encouraged the u.s. to stay put
even President Bush's Secretary of State
a critic of the deal cautions withdrawal
could spell trouble I would have
probably stayed in the deal just to kind
of manage the Allies in it who have a
lot at stake but it's not going to be
the end of the world if he does pull out
a consensus is emerging around one idea
in particular the current deal is
incomplete and parts of it need to be
fixed
urgently European allies and even
Secretary of Defense mattis have all
said recently steps must be taken to
address Ron's ballistic missile program
and it's attempts to destabilize the
Middle East